[Music]
I'm Michael dapper and I'm a creative
best way to play hey fried the journey
there's been so many different factors
you know I had to overcome you know
barrier is a fair inconsistency
believing in myself as an individual and
believing in the gift and believing that
this can actually happen and this is
like what I'm actually supposed to do
you got your mom in there and you're a
kind of telling me yo man don't get the
job that you know he exaggerated waist
of a mom when she's when she's in a
little zone you hear the African twang
pop up you know say you know say less so
yeah odors like so many different
factors you know I'm saying or Nothing
finding myself as an individual you know
I'm saying finding my faith for my
belief in God like my favor and belief
just in just like I said what is that
want to do well I think that the pivotal
point they mean was probably at the end
of 2015 at that point I was I probably
worked in Vodafone for about two years
part-time and you know I got to the
stage where I'd done I just didn't like
you know my job I didn't like what I was
doing I just always felt there was more
in my heart
for me to do creatively and one of my
close friends who was the person that
first kind of filmed a YouTube sketch of
mine when I was in college he
unfortunately took his on his own life
and that that rocked me differently
because I think I just like oh you know
CME's you that I'm thinking someone
that's so bright and had such a bright
future and was so enthusiastic has gone
all the way like to that point there and
I just thought you know what this is
just more to life than just dist you
know I'm saying so I just kind of just
went away it came back started creating
and creating curry and and you know fact
gods were here today and you know we've
got more to come so yeah
[Music]